ladies and gentlemen we have this tweet
from BBC News World wait what is this it
says why some people some people what do
you mean by some people oh my God are
spreading false rumors about the Texas
government Sheamus what do they mean
some people uh I don't know exactly what
they mean now I'm I'm gonna assume this
is some kind of racist dog whistle
because that's what it sounds like it is
and then they post this this picture of
me right and you know it looks like
they've darkened my skin I just can't
believe some people yeah what does this
mean
um I do think it's hilarious that they
said some people have just sang my name
and also how do people are spreading
false rumors also like a picture of me
well no and this is this is what's
really Insidious about this right so
they have some people that refers to a
group and then Texas gunman which refers
to one person so your brain goes to the
picture of the person there is the
gunman so it looks it really does when I
first saw this I was like oh is this
like a meme or something that like look
at the lefties are trying to joke that
Tim is responsible for this and so
they're possible so no they literally
posted your image actually Sinclair said
the same notice the same thing she
tweeted about she said that she said
that it was like disgusting that yeah I
made that title because it does look
like they're saying or implying that Tim
is the shooters yeah no it seriously it
does look like that it looks like that
it really does pick the picture that you
know could somewhat closely look like a
mug shot yeah oh
wowed it up a little bit if Tim made a
mob Deep album cover it would be that it
would be that picture yeah that's a fair
point because saying some people is a
reference to multiple people but that's
exactly singular Texas gunman showing
the image is to imply that was me I
think I might have to BBC I'm going to
sue you you got it you got to change
that I'm I'm gonna sue you I'm telling
you check it out though here's what they
say why some people are spreading false
rumors about the Texas gunman I this
article is actually hilarious because it
gives you a bunch of patter fluff
nonsense in the beginning that means
nothing that there's no point in Reading
it's just like there's a guy and he was
shooting people blah blah blah what did
the suspect post blah blah blah how do
we know how do we know the account was
his my favorite part the BBC has
examined the material and we can be
confident the suspect was the person
behind the posts hey confidence is not
confirmation so this is an opinion piece
BBC well so hold on yeah why are they
confident be like where's that outside
is coming from I know what their
confidence is coming from it fits their
narrative look at this look at this it
says Garcia appeared use the account uh
as an online diary he posted multiple
documents including his name date of
birth and other identifying details
including a plane ticket a speeding
ticket and an ID card
this is what we call in the business an
orgy of evidence
well I think you guys you guys get that
reference when you walk into a crime
scene and you see like all the documents
laid out perfectly it's like oh boy I
believe that wasn't that from Seven
where they talked about it no that was a
Minority Report there you go they go
into the room and there's all the photos
of Tom Cruise's kid and then uh Colin
Farrell's like this is what we call an
orgy of evidence it's it's not but it's
not believable like you walk in and
they're just like look here's the guy
who did it I think it's it's almost like
as absurd as if could you imagine if
there's a story that's as crazy as to
suggest that like maybe a plane crashed
and then like a passport survived the
Fireball and landed on the ground
thousands of people oh my gosh
and then uh anyway it says uh despite
the clear evidence the clear evidence
yeah they do that's a that's an opinion
right there yeah several activists and
internet personalities including at
least one mentioned Garcia's post have
attempted to cast doubt on the
authenticity of the material they've
claimed without evidence
it's part of a psychological operation
or false flag by the government to smear
those on the right or far right well I
didn't I didn't say any of that later
stuff false flag I did say psyop but say
up in in could include corporations in
private sector as well so you see how
they they they expand upon it take what
you say and then add context to it but I
love how then they're just like at the
bottom like a picture of me adding to
the misinformation blah blah blah where
they say uh was it the podcaster Tim
Poole a former Occupy Wall Street
supporter and Vice news reporter was
among those mentioned several times I
got a I got a message earlier today
because the USA Today also talked about
me and they called me a former
journalist I'm like oh okay sure thanks
they're so they're so threatened there's
no evidence that Garcia was inspired to
action by Mr pool's podcasts which cover
right wing talking points and
conspiracies oh my gosh Mr pool
immediately tried to cast doubt on the
veracity to the material accusing those
digging up the material as being part of
a psyop yes yes uh BBC your opinion
piece is interesting to me but please
spare me your opinion piece and don't
use my photo in the way you did but I
would like to point out
um what do we have here a couple weeks
before this this incident someone
started posting random photos from
Reddit and posting uh four clips from
Tim cast IRL a single episode and making
a photo post about Libs of tick tock to
no followers to nobody for what reason a
a Mexican
Neo-Nazi inspired by a Jewish woman and
a mixed race Korean guy is is what what
are they trying to imply and the Nazi
stuff I just think is the most absurd
considering they're like Libs of tick
tock is great it's like
higher right check is Jewish
stupidest thing I've ever heard of and
so anyway
that's the story and then I go that
sounds like BS oh wait but BBC better
write up a whole article about it and
put his picture in it well thanks for
that BBC appreciate it
the existence of the CIA at all means
that all conspiracy theories are at
least plausible
period if it exists like how many times
has there been you know covert
operations that have come to light that
the CIA was involved in coin uh cointel
Pro what was it called
so this is this is Belling cat that uh
uncovered this uh this this profile how
like the serious question a balancat
researcher just so happened to be
browsing Russian social media
underground social media and found a
profile with no followers come on dude
the same guy that connected the um New
York Times with the uh
the Ukraine it's information laundering
what they do is they bellingcat can
write whatever they want and then say oh
look at this this is interesting then
the media writes it up and they can't be
sued that's how it works and
bellingcat's a non-profit which is very
very difficult to get money out of so in
my humble opinion I believe at the very
least the balling cat people are so bad
at their jobs they genuinely believe
random garbage on the internet let me
tell you how easy it is make a profile
make 10 profiles post a series of images
about a specific individual you want to
smear so uh right now someone could go
on a Russian website and make a profile
where they post a bunch of pictures of
Hasidic Jewish Nazis seemingly making no
sense no pictures of faces or anything
like that they can then write posts and
then wait and then as soon as something
happens they can take the picture of the
individual upload it as the profile
picture then add demographic information
birth date location and the BBC will be
like well the birth date matches that
proves it even though they made the
profile in advance and I'm not saying
it's a having to do it and I'm not
saying that it's an intelligence
intelligence agency I'm saying literally
any activist can do this right now any
random person sitting in their mom's
basement can do this right now so for
you to be like we're confident it's it's
actually the account is just nonsense
well again shut up the people who
believe Jessie small at right right the
people who believe Jessie smallette yeah
well you don't is it I know all the bad
guys and I'm just saying look like it
it's just I think if you did have a
lunatic who had posted a couple clips
from Tim's show obviously it goes
without saying that that doesn't make
Tim at all culpable for the behavior of
That League I wasn't even so yeah the
clips Joe he wasn't even subscribed to
the channel wow right like he's a fan
like he wasn't even subscribed it was it
was four clips from one show but yeah so
my point is this is grasping at straws
right because even if they can
definitively prove even if it turns out
that this is legitimate that really is
this guy's profile they're telling the
truth and they have good reasons to be
confident that still is not the nail in
the coffin that they think it is here I
I mean I gotta be honest like I think
it's funny and I really just don't care
I think we've won so much ground in the
culture war that it is completely
meaningless that they would even do it
assuming it was a Psy up it's just it
means nothing to me it's just it's just
funny the fact that every chance they
get there they're just slandering you
know like musk or Tim cast or whoever it
is that is the uh opposing view it's
straight slander just associations with
the most terrible organization in
history the Nazis right here that's just
it's it shows that they have no no
substance here's our here's how I
responded Ian miles Chong tweeted
something out Keith olberman responded
saying sure it's suspect because your
side and Libs of tick tock got caught
inspiring a mass murderer blood on your
hands Fu and I said I really don't care
what the cult thinks like at all fart
fart Keith elberman I'd say you're dumb
as a box of rocks but that's a demeaning
to rocks
like I I just do I care about what
ranting raving lunatic Keith Olbermann
thinks he thought he thought Donald
Trump was it was a Russian spy like
these people are not smart people and
there's nothing like you know uh they
try to shame you and I'm just like I you
know I you can't shame me well your
booze mean nothing I've seen what makes
you cheer exactly I mean for for any
story especially if it's something that
suits their narrative you really need to
see hard proof from them in order to
give it any level of credibility but I
just don't care Keith olberman could
come out and be like look at this
picture of a thing happening and I just
laugh at him like you are a really dumb
guy and your words are meaningless and
there's no reason for me to read them
like there is nothing Keith olberman can
say that will impact my life in any
meaningful way politically media wise I
just I I don't care about these people
but it's not just him it's like I've
gotten to the point where in the culture
War a leftist can come and start going
in my ears and I'm just like it does
nothing but it has no bearing whatsoever
it's like you said it's all it's all
about narrative control because
ostensibly it's it's about oh there was
a shooting and it's tragic and you know
they want us to believe that this is a a
Mexican like it's a bold claim to say
it's a Mexican white supremacist and
they will they will use the tragedy to
obsessively run that narrative when at
the same time there was other shootings
that happened like there was a shooting
that happened in Tulsa Oklahoma right
around that same time
um you know I don't as far as I know
nobody watched your show on that
shooting so that's not the one that they
choose they choose the one where they
have to make the claim that it's a
Mexican white supremacist just to be
able to say that it's somebody who's
watching SO waiting on that uh Las Vegas
shooter motivation yeah remember that
one or the manifesto from the the
Covenant shooting so that that that
Nashville incident as well as the Vegas
one we still haven't figured out those
have we that was 20 minutes from my
daughter was going to a private school
like 20 minutes away from there they hit
close to home but yeah we don't we don't
hear much about that and that was a
Christian School the fact that the fact
that you have almost no info or had so
had to wait so long to get information
about the Nashville shooter the the
manifesto is still not out but this had
so much information the very next day
and you're not supposed to be suspect
you're if you're skeptical at all it's
it's it's verboten to be skeptical give
me a break and the other thing I've
noticed looking at the coverage of this
uh and this has to be part of the
narrative control too is every single
article has the same talking point of
over 200 mass shootings this year yeah
all of them and they all site the same
non-profit yeah and they all cite the
same non-profit uh that is saying this
now that non-profit says there's been
1200 defensive uses of guns that's
ridiculous anybody who knows about that
statistic knows that there's there's
hundreds of thousands of defensive uses
of guns every year so it makes you
wonder how the hell are they defining a
mass shooting to come to that number
it's usually three or more people being
injured by a firearm and so what they'll
do is this little bait and switch where
they have have one definition of a mass
shooting that says something depending
on the definition you're looking at
either three people being injured with a
firearm or three people being killed and
when people hear mass shooting of course
they don't think that that's where the
bar is they're thinking of a school
shooting they're thinking of a large
group of people being massacred so yeah
I think three people being injured by a
firearm is a very different thing from a
public Massacre but you use the way the
term is used paints a picture that 200
separate times this year already there
have been these massive you know
Columbine level events exactly when you
use the phrase mass shooting it brings
to mind Columbine or Virginia Tech or
Parkland or any other horrible horrible
horrible shootings and when they say
when you're talking about 200 of them so
far this year they're talking about two
probably really terrible shootings and
990 and you know and 198 that are are
three people took rounds when two when a
drug deal went bad and that's what a man
shooting is exactly and that's one thing
so a lot of it is like gang activities
drug deals someone pulling out a gun
again that's not a good thing that's not
a thing we want to tolerate in our
country we want to clean that up but
that is not something that belongs in
the same category as an event like a
school shoot yeah and that's the thing
it's this they're bringing to mind the
school shooting so it's the most
horrible event that you that that
happens in America it puts you in the
most emotional state where you might be
the most reactive and the most accepting
of a narrative it's also very
understanding of how people read
information like this one like you know
most people will read the headline
they'll read maybe the first couple
lines in there and they'll come to their
conclusions but you have to post
something like this BBC article
specifically because of the way that
people look for information we want to
confirm what we already kind of believe
so if we want to look up something like
this and we see it okay okay yeah sure
it makes perfect sense and you know it
writes off Tim in a very like
interesting dismissive way
so this is also very intelligent on how
people peruse their information and come
to their conclusions and just validate
what they've already been I particularly
like this headline from unheard don't
blame Tim pool for the Texas mall
shooting that's really nice
look at the picture too so what are you
doing I think I look pretty good but
it's kind of like a shrugging right I
think that's your outro actually what it
Clips your outro one other thing that I
want to point out is that the Centrist
media personality see thank you unheard
the mass shooter stuff is actually dual
use right so one thing it it can
demonize people or groups of people they
can use it to say oh these people are
saying the wrong things blah blah and on
the second point it gives them a route
to attack rifles which rifles are the
tools that will keep a tyrannical
government at bay that's why they are
after rifles and they're not after
machine gun guns they're not after tank
Busters grenades thereafter rifles
that's because of Vietnam because of
Afghanistan because all over the world
if you have a population that's armed
with rifles that can take shots at three
four five hundred yards they can harass
a well-equipped army and they can
basically wait them out and that's the
last thing that the government wants to
have to deal with they want to get rid
of the rifles so that way they can go
ahead and say all right we're going to
Institute this particular law that
violates your rights and people are in a
position or not in a position to say no
we're going to put our foot down thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time